il termine fab lab è diventato molto
ricorrente negli ultimi mesi anche nel
nostro paese ogni qual volta ci siamo
ritrovati a parlare di innovazione di
sviluppo di nuovi modelli di mercato e
di strategie di resistenza alla crisi ma
l'idea di che cosa sia un fab lab
di che cosa si faccia al suo interno e
soprattutto del perché dovremmo ritenere
un'opportunità la diffusione di questo
modello è un'idea che è ancora piuttosto
nebulosa non vi nego che la maggior
parte dei miei amici non hanno ancora
capito che cosa faccia quando dico che
lavoro in un fab lab fab lab sta
letteralmente per fabrication laboratori
un sistema che nasce da un'idea che
aveva avuto un docente universitario del
mit resosi conto del fatto che i suoi
studenti avessero un'ottima preparazione
dal punto di vista teorico ma che non
fossero più assolutamente in grado di
mettere in pratica quello che avevano
appreso ho immaginato questo docente
illuminato nel 1998 istitui un corso
come costruirsi quasi qualsiasi cosa
come risposta a questa incapacità
pratica il corso riscosse un enorme
successo tanto che nel 2002 all'interno
del mit apre i battenti il vero primo
fab lab
era un posto dove la preparazione
teorica riscopriva il valore
dell'esperienza pratica si producevano
oggetti e soluzioni tangibili
noi ci siamo innamorati della
declinazione fabulous regola 3 perché
crediamo che ci rappresenti al meglio
favoloso è una parola che si racconta da
solo e meraviglioso è incantevole non ha
bisogno di grandi spiegazioni è legato a
una parola latina fabula re che
significa raccontare conversare
insomma noi crediamo che in favoloso
stia la
divisione della meraviglia del processo
creativo laboratorio e poi una parola
altrettanto ricca perché ha una duplice
valenza è il luogo per eccellenza della
ricerca scientifica ma allo stesso tempo
e la bottega artigiana ed è in qualche
modo legato a una parola che sembra
diventata desueta lavoro il fab lab è un
progetto alimentato da sogni ambiziosi e
da sviluppi concreti nutrito nel qual
modo da una parte di cielo e da una
parte di terra il fab lab nascono
tendenzialmente all'interno delle
università o inabili industriali ma più
tipicamente si autoproducono in ambiti
urbani e si diffondono in maniera virale
così è successo un po anche a noi
un gruppo di amici studenti colleghi
curiosi che semplicemente cercavano di
dare una risposta a una parola che
intristiva i nostri orizzonti crisi non
possiamo pretendere che le cose cambino
se continuiamo a fare le stesse cose e
allora abbiamo cercato di fare cose
altre abbiamo raccolto racconti di
installazioni artistiche di artigianato
digitale di prototipazione rapida di
coworking di nomadismo professionale
tutto ciò ha generato un grande
entusiasmo è una grande voglia di fare
davanti a un idea che in quel momento
non nego che sembrava molto vicina alla
pura utopia
in realtà ci siamo resi conto che
stavamo tracciando il solco per un
progetto che poteva veramente generare
cultura nuove prospettive e lo ripeto
ancora lavoro cosa si fa concretamente
all'interno di un fab lab all'interno di
un fab lab è fondamentale fare cose
quale sviluppare un modello
tridimensionale usare una stampante per
di e avere una certa confidenza con un
piccolo processore chiamato arduino
queste tecnologie fino a poco tempo fa
erano accessibili a poche persone perché
avevano dei costi molto alti
l'abbassamento della barriera del costo
ha consentito un utilizzo molto più
diffuso ha caratterizzato una nuova
generazione di artigiani cosiddetti
artigiani digitali ma è molto riduttivo
pensare che all'interno di un fab lab
semplice semplicemente si giochi con
delle stampanti 3d o con arduino
all'interno di un fab lab si lavora su
progetti si realizzano prototipi si
costruiscono installazioni artistiche si
testano sistemi e si lanciano piccole
produzioni si attivano sempre modi
diversi per farlo
condividendo sapere ibridi e soprattutto
mettendo a disposizione a livello
globale
quelli che sono i risultati di quanto
fatto e appreso durante il cammino non
solo parallelamente si cerca anche di
tracciare le prospettive per dei nuovi
modelli imprenditoriali
proviamo a fare un esempio di come
funziona io sono una giovane designer
bergamasca e voglio regalare ad un'amica
che abita a new york city un anello sul
mio disegno
preparo il mio schizzo su carta mi reco
al fab lab dove trovo qualcuno che mi
aiuta a trasformare la mia idea
semplicemente disegnato con la matita in
un modello tridimensionale
il modello molto semplicemente una volta
realizzato tramite una mail viene
inviato al fab lab di new york dove
trova un altro tecnico che raccolta la
mail lancia la stampa in 3d e realizza
l'anello secondo le indicazioni di
materiale coloritura che io ho
semplicemente allegato alla mail una
volta stampato l'anello potrebbe essere
incartato con una carta artigianale che
un cartiere locale ha insegnato
nuovamente a produrre ai giovani new
york maker un sms avviserà la mia amica
che un regalo l'attende al fab lab è un
modo molto diverso
di far acquisire un senso ed un valore
ad un oggetto nonché ai gesti e alle
relazioni e che sono sottointese sembra
favoloso vero ma quanto durerà questa
moda i fab lab hanno innato nella loro
vocazione alla diffusione virale il
rischio di rapida estinzione perché
perché
capite che sono oggetto di facile
propaganda e retorica perché potrebbero
non avere i mezzi per auto sostenersi
economicamente perché la condivisione
sulla carta è meravigliosa ma nella vita
di tutti i giorni è una faccenda davvero
complicata perché il fatto che la
tecnologia possa essere diffusa tra
tanti non significa che automaticamente
tanti abbiano delle buone idee perché i
fab lab possono essere fraintesi e
acchiappati comune idea di business
facile
oppure il fab lab stessi possono
spegnersi in derive utopiche tutte
queste obiezioni potrebbero sembrare
obiezioni sensate ma sono obiezioni che
si rifanno una grammatica di pensiero
economica e sociale che non può più
essere considerata universalmente valida
un fab lab per essere significativo e
produttivo deve essere soprattutto
diverso alessandro baricco ci insegna
che il futuro è per dei selvaggi di
genio i selvaggi di genio sono coloro
che hanno già fatto propria la
grammatica di pensiero che metterà il
futuro nelle loro mani sono quelli che
condividono spazi creativi virtuali e
reali sono quelli che hanno deciso che
può essere rivoluzionato il principio di
proprietà intellettuale sono quelli che
autoproducono e sono quelli che hanno
deciso di non aspettare ma il futuro è
anche per i custodi della modernità
passata
che hanno deciso di riscrivere il valore
della loro esperienza sono artigiane che
hanno portato le loro macchine
all'interno dei fab lab e le hanno
rimesse in funzione insieme ai nuovi
artigiani digitali sono imprenditori che
hanno deciso che la riparabilità di un
oggetto può diventare o tornare ad
essere un valore aggiunto alla
produzione sono scuole accademie e
università che hanno deciso di
convogliare in un unico hub condiviso
tutta la loro esperienza creativa
favorendo l'idea di intelligenza
collettiva e di creatività di un'intera
comunità piuttosto che quella di piccoli
e singoli gruppi
la nostra ambizione è quella di
costruire i ponti lungo i quali selvaggi
e custodi possano muoversi incontrarsi
entrare in relazione e fare quali sono
le parole che accompagneranno queste
persone lungo questi ponti etica
artigianato digitale innovazione diffusa
lavoro scegliete quelle che più vi
appartengono e fate le vostre che siate
custodi o selvaggi di genio
noi vi aspettiamo sarà favoloso
costruisco il mio ponte pensando a gaia
giorgio che sono un futuro futuro e oggi
lo illumina